Genghis Khan the name that is synonymous
with barbaric cruelty and conquest 800
years ago he created the greatest army
the world has ever known
wielding it with tactical brilliance to
lay claim to the largest empire in world
history no other man alexander napoleon
or hitler ever came close to the level
of success in conquest of the mongolian
man of steel so how did he do it well in
today's by graphics we discover how a
simple peasant rose from one of the
harshest environments on the planet to
take the world by storm
we know about the early life of this man
who would rise to rule the world comes
from an account called the secret
history of the mongols written soon
after he died it tells us the genghis
was born somewhere in the steppes of
central asia around the Year 1165 it is
said that he was born with a clot of
blood in his hand which was seen as a
portent of great things to come
genghis was born into a harsh
unforgiving world the mongols who lacked
a common chief were broken into a number
of clans who were constantly warring
with each other the landscape was vast
and rugged situated between europe and
china it consisted of an inhospitable
series of rolling hills rocky outcrops
and freezing temperatures the Chinese
referred to the region as the barbarian
wilderness and built a great wall to
keep its inhabitants from raiding their
border regions for the Mongols strength
was found in numbers large families were
encouraged with polygamy and accepted
custom Genghis his father had two wives
the boy's mother had been abducted from
her previous husband in another tribe as
a boy Genghis grew up with three
brothers a sister and two half-brothers
his earliest years were spent hunting
riding and ramming the plains as part of
a nomadic society as clan were
constantly on the move seeking new
pastures whenever the grazing for their
sheep was exhausted Genghis is reported
to have grown up as a brave and a fine
young man it's only fear being dogs yet
he was an introvert who preferred to
spend the bulk of his time alone with
his thoughts he was fiercely independent
seeing no value in consultation with
others as he emerged into his teens it
was apparent to all that he had a sense
of his own destiny and that destiny lay
far beyond the clan that was then his
world as was the custom at around 9
years old Genghis his parents arranged a
marriage for their son his wife-to-be
was named burtom who was from a
neighboring tribe and Genghis was to be
transferred to that camp so that he
could grow up alongside his bride on the
return trip after delivering his son
Genghis his father met a party of Tatars
on their way to a hunting expedition
they seemed hospitable offering him food
and drink however the offerings they
were laced with poison and three days
later his father died
Ghengis quickly returned to the
fatherless family who were abandoned by
the rest of the clan his mother
Harleen now assumes the mantle of
headship within the household there was
constant friction between the three sons
of Helen and their two stepbrothers one
day when he was 13 years of age Genghis
was holding a fish that he had caught
when one of his step brothers came up
and snatched it from his hands without
hesitation genghis drew his bow and
killed the boy this was the first clear
demonstration of the absolute
ruthlessness that would come to
characterize the boy who would become
the Great Khan by the age of 15 genghis
was stronger bigger and more skillful in
hunting and horsemanship than his
brothers his brothers began to bow to
him as their natural leader his
reputation as a strong warrior began to
spread soon the clan that had deserted
his family when his father had died got
to hear of this upstart fearing that he
might lead his brothers against them he
decided to take the initiative by
invading the family's encampment and
taking genghis captive but youngest was
able to escape the invaders fanned out
into the wilderness and nine days later
they found him genghis was taken
prisoner and a heavy wooden yoke was
placed around his neck a couple of days
later and waka Angus was languishing
inside a guarded tent with the yoke
still around his neck his captors threw
a celebratory party despite the
inconvenience of the yoke genghis
managed to overpower his guard he got
down to the river before his absence was
discovered unable to traverse the river
while wearing the yoke he then returned
to the tents from which he had come
there he found the guard he had recently
overpowered genghis then displayed the
shrewdness of thinking which was to set
him apart he told the guards that unless
he got him out of the yoke and gave him
a horse he would tell the others that
the guard had helped him escape
the black nail worked and he was soon
galloping away from his captors
a year later at age 16 Genghis returned
to the village of Berta
the girl he had been pledged to at the
time of his father's death it was time
to get married as a wedding gift the
girl's father gave him a spectacular
sable coat the next day genghis took his
wife back to his encampment and left her
in the care of his mother he then rode
off to a neighboring clan where he
presented his new coat as a gift of the
chief Dame by the name of torille in
doing so genghis was purchasing the
allegiance of this powerful clan leader
he asked a girl to help him win back the
loyalty of the tribesmen who deserted
his family after his father's death
Tyrell was sympathetic and the pact was
formed between them news of the alliance
it soon spread other clans offered their
support and before long genghis was able
to call upon a formidable force of
warriors before he could put them into
action however disaster struck invading
market horseman came thundering across
the plains intent on kidnapping the
women of genghis is camp the majority of
the clan managed to escape but genghis
is young wife Berta was taken captive by
the markets genghis desperately rode for
the camp of Tugrul for help
tog role announced that he would ride
upon the markets and destroy them
returning Berta to her husband's over
the next few months the Alliance managed
to bring together more than 5000
warriors in order to ride with them the
attack was swift and decisive the Mongol
hordes decimated the market camp killing
looting and pillaging without mercy in
the midst of the camp they found Berta
she had been raped repeatedly and was
pregnant shortly after returning to camp
she gave birth to a son but it was never
known if it was genghis child or one of
the market rapists
in the wake of the overthrow of the
markets genghis went from strength to
strength he united with the clan of his
boyhood friend
jamika the two men became inseparable
declaring themselves blood brothers they
lived together ate together and slept
together this roused the jealousy of
genghis wife and mother he began to
spread rumors about Jammu here in an
attempt to drive the two men apart
whether it was the influence of the
women in his life or his own lust for
absolute power something caused genghis
to sever the bond with jamika in 1185
the two plans were moving towards
fertile grazing grounds when jamika
decided to turn off in camp in a valley
he called to Genghis to join him that
Genghis ignored him and kept on riding
carrying on a mile so he turned in his
saddle to see that not only had his own
Klansmen followed him but many of
Jamaica's men had as well genghis was
now developing the largest following of
any of the mongrel clans this was
achieved partly through the desire for
security in numbers and partly by
coercion those who did not agree to give
Genghis their allegiance while they were
forced to do so the combination of his
desire for power and wealth and his need
to feed his ever-expanding following led
to repeated raids on other clans the
capture of their women and the
plundering of their belongings the
secret history of the Mongols previous
equates to Genghis which may be familiar
to fans of the 1982 movie Conan the
Barbarian in which the words were given
to arnold schwarzenegger as character
the greatest pleasure is to vanquish
your enemies and chase them before you
to rob them of their wealth and see
those dear to them bathed in tears to
ride their horses and clasp to your
bosom their wives and daughters at this
point still in his early 20s genghis had
already proved himself to be brilliant
at psychological warfare he would attack
a tribe with horrific and devastating
force in order to intimidate the
surrounding camps to give up without a
fight as a result many thousands of his
enemies simply surrendered in order to
avoid the carnage that would result if
they resisted having subjugated and
melded into one the disparate Mongol
clans
Genghis now set his sights on the
farthest reaches of the barbarian
wilderness among those who had not yet
joined his alliance was his former best
friend Jammu ko who was now his mortal
enemy the people of the two camps had
been able to maintain a sort of uneasy
peace however one day a disagreement
over grazing lands erupted into violence
with one of genghis men killing all
warrior from Jammu cos camp an outrage
jamika reacted by attacking the much
larger camp of Genghis the
unexpectedness and lightning speed of
the rage resulted in the killing of many
and the capture of 70 of genghis
chieftains who were taken back to Jammu
coos camp where they were tortured and
boiled alive genghis he was shocked to
his core at this humiliating defeat he
came to the realization that his army
was not yet ready to engage in the
large-scale conquests that he had
envisions consequently he set out to
mold them into a war machine a breed of
warrior the likes of which had never
been seen before the army that resulted
was incredibly mobile able to travel an
average of 70 miles per day the men were
subjected to the most severe discipline
in order to forge their minds and bodies
into warrior like steel
before long the reputation of the
Barbarian super army spread beyond the
boundaries of Mongolia when the rulers
of the Qin Empire in China heard about
them they invited Genghis to come and
help them fight off marauding bands that
artists who were constantly harassing
them the Tatars were also longtime
enemies of the mongols and genghis saw
this as an opportunity to exact
vengeance while expanding his reach
internationally in short order the
overpowering force of the mongols
crushed the tatars returning to triumph
in their home country genghis Asami was
immediately attacked by Jamaica's forces
this time however genghis was ready over
a series of three bloody encounters
Jamaica's followers were finally
subjugated Jamaica however managed to
escape fleeing to the sanctity of the
niners a powerful tribe dwelling in the
northwesterly region of the steppes
when news reached Genghis that jamika
joined the name and he set his sights on
destroying them he unleashed his 80,000
strong cavalry against them totally
overpowering them in a frenzy of
bloodletting amazingly however Jammu
kept managed to escape once again he hit
with a small plan of Mountain dwellers
but they fearing the wrath of the
invaders betrayed Jammu Khan and handed
him over to the camp of Genghis Genghis
though he was shot by the lack of
loyalty to Jammu command he had them all
slaughtered
then he extended mercy to Jammu Co with
an offer of a pardon
the Jukka refused and begged to be put
to death a ceding to his wish Genghis
allowed his old friend to be suffocated
to death inside a carpet despite his
reputation as an unfeeling executioner
genghis turned away unable to watch the
scene
having defeated the diamonds genghis was
now the supreme ruler of in excess of 2
million people
having had a taste of supreme power he
now wanted more that were still parts of
Mongolia that were not part of his
Empire these were areas along the
eastern and southern regions of the
country over a period of months he
systematically beat into submission
those who had not yet come under his
yoke Genghis rode at the very front of
his ferocious hordes personally
overseeing every detail of the attack
but his greatest skill lay in his
ability to handpick brilliant generals
in doing so he managed to United people
who had for centuries been at war with
one another in 1206 the people made
Genghis their supreme ruler bestowing
upon him the title of Khan the great
leader as recorded in the secret history
of the Mongols the people proclaimed we
will make you our leader our Great Khan
we will fling ourselves like lightning
upon your foes we shall give you the
fairest girls from the enemy if we
disobey you take our flocks and our
wives and our children and throw are
worthless heads upon the sand between
military conquests Genghis enjoyed the
rewards of success he gathered more
wives and fathered more children by his
first wife Burton he had four sons who
would each be given rulership over a
part of his Empire despite the wealth
luxury and family with which he now
surrounded himself Genghis was tormented
by vivid dreams in which he was
continually riding in the conquest of
one land after another impelled by these
dreams and his own innate ambition he
became fixated on the vast lands that
lay beyond the Great Wall on his
southern border
in 1206 genghis called together a great
summit of his generals and tribal
leaders to discuss his planned invasion
of China between Mongolia and China lay
the kingdom of Asiya the land of the
Tang Goods this was a key trade route
between Central Asia and the West
genghis undertook a campaign of conquest
that within two years brought the entire
kingdom of assayer
under his domain the way it was now
opened to invade China in an effort to
capitalize on his previous dealings with
the Qin Empire Khan sent a peace envoy
over the wall Qin authorities however
they were suspicious of the visitors and
they put them to death on hearing of
this outcome genghis took to his tent
and fasted for three days he emerged to
announce that the heavens had declared
that he would be victorious and the time
to wreak vengeance upon the qin was now
with 40,000 cavalry men riding behind
him genghis crossed the border smashing
over the wall and into china
they then swept down upon the Qin Empire
they approached with unrivaled speed and
quiet until almost upon the enemy when
the thundering of their horses hooves
shook the grounds the attacks that
followed were overwhelming crushing
their enemies and destroying their
encampments it was during the Qin
campaign that the ruthlessness of
Genghis Khan became legendary he would
use captured women and children as human
shields in battle forcing them to march
ahead of his army as they approached an
enemy village within two years of first
invading China genghis had reached the
capital of the Qin Empire jong-du which
is modern-day Beijing the great city was
encircled by a wall and strongly
fortified Khan's army laid siege for
almost a year finally with the aid of
siege towers and catapults the Mongols
managed to breach the wall after a
fierce battle and at the cost of
thousands of Chinese lives the city fell
after subjugating the Qin Empire Genghis
rode back to the steppe country of his
birth but it wasn't long before the
spirit of conquest once more fired his
ambition he now looked to the world
beyond China he looked to the fringe of
Europe between China and Europe lay the
vast Islamic empire known as quorus on
this area was ruled by a Shah who had
power that equaled that of Genghis
himself but Khan did not wish to
subjugate the lands of the Shah he
sought only peace sending a caravan of
envoy's to Khorasan yes just after they
crossed the border and all of his men
they were captured and slaughtered and
enraged genghis sends another group of
envoy's this time instructing them to go
to
to the shop they too were murdered by
Islamic soldiers for Genghis who
believed in the absolute inviolability
of envoy's this was far too much the
time for vengeance was once again at
hands he set out at the head of his
largest army to date more than 200,000
men years of savage butchery were
unleashed upon the Muslim people by the
time the bloodletting subsided genghis
khan had wrestled absolute power away
from the shop his vast empire now
spanned from the Yellow Sea in the East
all the way to the Caspian in the West
before returning to the steps Genghis
Khan appointed his son Guga day as the
heir he now faced the problem of
controlling his vast empire in the
summer of 12 26 he wrote to the head of
a hundred and eighty thousand warriors
to crush an uprising among the tangled
people before he got to them however he
fell from his horse and suffered serious
injuries and internal bleeding over the
coming months he only got worse on
August the 18th 12 26 and at the height
of his powers he died Genghis Khan's
legacy would be cemented by his grandson
Kublai Khan who extended the Mongolian
Empire to encompass two continents and
to become the largest empire in history
perhaps Khan's most enduring
contribution however was this although
forged through unspeakable violence his
conquests brought about a peace and
stability that enabled the first ever
flow of trade and ideas between the
eastern and western worlds so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did hit that thumbs up button below
and don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday also over there on the right
some other videos from the archives
which you can definitely check out and
if you want us to do a biography on a
certain person head over to our website
that's the best way to do it you can
find a link to it in the description
below and then in the bar you'll see
like a voting area go over there suggest
someone to us and we're gonna make the
more popular ones so we're open to your
feedback guys and as always thanks for
watching